what does writing a marketable
screenplay mean great question probably
one of my favorite questions I often say
that you can have a great idea super
high concept and I think I referenced
previously I've heard story ideas ago oh
my god
that is great I want option before I
even read it and then I read it and it's
not well executed so if you have a great
concept that's not well executed chances
are that it will not sell if you have a
high concept that is well executed you
have a much better chance of it getting
salt conversely you can have a project
that is totally not high concept but if
it is beautifully executed it then
becomes marketable so for example if we
take a movie like Juno and I'll define
high concept high concept is the
hangover a bunch of guys you know from
the movie poster I mean a lot of people
I know a lot of your audience knows what
high concept is but there are those who
don't and it's terminology we use
Alliance basically where the concept is
very big and immediately recognizable
like from a movie poster so The Hangover
and it's the guys are you know we all
know it's The Hangover in its Vegas you
can tell from the movie poster and they
all look like they're Iraq and it's the
48 hours before bachelor is to walk down
the aisle at his bachelor party they go
to Vegas and I his friends lose him and
they have now fought and don't have any
recollection of what happened the night
before and have 48 hours to find him
before the wedding that's one example of
big big concept speed is a big concept
anything that's based on a brand like
transformers it has a immediately
recognizable built-in audience brand
value so the opposite of that would be a
movie like Slumdog Millionaire in fact
most of the movies that when the Oscars
are not high concept Slumdog Millionaire
Million Dollar Baby okay if you were to
pitch this I'm gonna do a you know not
justice to the movie but if you think
about it like trying to get a studio to
this is a story about a girl who comes
from a trailer park and she wants to be
a boxer and she's mentored by this older
dude and she winds up getting entering
herself to the point where she becomes
paralyzed on the way down and she
paralyzed from the waist down and
basically asks him as an act of kindness
to do euthanasia
so she does okay who would buy that not
you know Slumdog Millionaire this is was
a great story creep movie no known act
American actor but you did have a an
a-list director Danny Boyle so that is
what definitely helped get it made and
it was also based on a book swing blade
another one magnificently written script
and some of these movies have definitely
be harder to get done today but the you
take Juno you you know family drama
teenage girl gets pregnant I mean really
that used to be like an after-school
special or in no disrespect you know
more of a TV movie than a feature that
would build such a big following this
year Lady Bird you know that's not a
high concept rite of passage with the
young girl and but it was so well
written and it resonated so much with
people the mother-daughter relationship
the notion of growing up in a small town
and so the what makes a script
marketable the script like Juno and with
Lady Bird the the quality of the writing
the freshness of the characters the
truthfulness of the characters that then
becomes marketable so that
comes down to me saying write your best
work I don't know any executives other
people may I don't know any executives
who have optioned a script if they
didn't care for the dialogue the writing
they didn't think it was
I mean structure maybe is the least
offensive you know I didn't I can be a
good idea and maybe the structure is not
great but they're the the characters are
compelling The Situation's compelling
and the dialogue is good and I just
don't know anyone who buy scripts if
those elements aren't there so therefore
I think if you are gonna make a
profession as a screenwriter it's not an
easy profession at all you have to roll
up your sleeves and really get in there
and I I read I mean I'm working right
now with someone who just graduated from
film school and it's quite his his
writings were really good there are some
elements that I think needed to be much
more pronounced what the underlying
theme is and the purpose of the journey
and some things that didn't track with
the characters but there's a lot of
talent there but I didn't think it's
ready quite to take out yet but he's
doing some work now and he'll get there
I mean there's there's a there's a lot
of talent and there's a lot of there's a
lot of writing that really isn't very
strong and I think the biggest death to
a writer is to is to not be able to take
notes well and I don't mean just any
notes to be open to constructive
feedback and to want to put in their
dues so I think that's the biggest
killer as well as trying to please too
many people and not listening to your
own inner voice and I just say in terms
of marketability what gets agents
attention producers studio networks is a
is that you'll hear a strong voice that
there's something really fresh about a
person has a point of view and that the
character writing the Quentin Tarantino
is such a strong voice and I would say
that Greta Gerwig you know as a strong
voice and we could go on but yeah I
can't think of their names but yeah and
even what's going back to Lady Bird just
just briefly we went to see the post and
unfortunately the movie didn't play so
we all had to leave the theater but I
talked to a man who was maybe in his
late 50s and he said he loved Lady Bird
so here's someone that it's not even
really you would think that wouldn't be
the audience right but he said and he
was recommending it to the people he was
with we were kind of talking about it so
you can see how he somehow resonated
with that voice and I mean it's a great
suit the truthfulness of that
mother-daughter relationship which
wasn't pretty
you know how they got in each other's
faces and talked to each other but it's
was truthful and we know that they they
did love each other and you know so
touching towards latter part of the
movie when the mother who was really
kind of you know really tough with her
daughter and the daughter didn't feel
like she really loved her even liked her
and then we saw that she was trying to
write a letter to her and crumbled it up
like 30 times that's a that's another
form of love versus this would be the
boring way of doing it and not so
truthful to the human experience would
be well you know I love you maybe I'm
hard on you but maybe I'm doing it for
your own good or maybe have my own
issues so I'm not really able to love
that well versus the simple beautiful
act that she was crumpling up letters
because she want to find the right words
and couldn't that says so much more than
anything that's on the nose and obvious
we reading the whole part of coming from
a smaller town even though it's
California's capital but there is a
small-town feel to Sacramento for
anybody who's driven through it and and
wanting to like really rien
yourself yes oh she didn't want to go by
her given name I wanted to be a writer
on the East Coast right it wasn't okay
to to be a writer from California you
know and and just wanting to reinvent or
say and I think everyone can identify
with versus you know no and so that's
just really wonderful writing versus I
want to I want to be a writer I'm tired
of being in the small town I want to
reinvent myself you know so that's
that's what although that's such a good
example of why you know some people say
what they get the feedback about not to
write expositionally what do you mean
white people can talk about like what
you don't like people to be direct sure
there's a time in place and sometimes
people are direct but most of the time
they're circling trying to figure out
their lives who they are and so on and
that was a very beautiful example of
that yeah I agree
you